foreign
complexity
my name is omkar and I'm the product
lead for architecture framework with me
joining here is Rakesh who is outbound
product manager on Google Cloud's Ops
management
today we are going to talk about
managing Day 2 operations on Google
Cloud where they will cover architecture
framework and highlight few key themes
to optimize your deployments
Rakesh will walk you through our
operations portfolio and we'll dive into
few important topics along with new
Google Cloud products and features that
will help you efficiently manage data
operations
now let's get started
I want to introduce you to the Google
Cloud architecture framework a set of
canonical best practices to help you
design build and operate a cloud
environment that secure efficient
resilient High performing and cost
effective the architecture framework
consists of six pillars each focused on
a specific topic highlighting key areas
critical to designing and operating your
workloads
the system design pillar is a
foundational pillar which includes
Google Cloud products features and
design principles that are Amplified
across the other five pillars
today we will talk about day to
operation which focuses primarily on
operation Excellence pillar but also
covers few topic across reliability
there are three key themes to optimize
your data operations
one designing resilient Services which
primarily revolves around ensuring you
standardize your deployments and
incorporate automation wherever possible
two understand tools available to you
especially how can you focus on
improving operational excellence then
managing the tool itself
and three how Google Cloud fully managed
tools help improve your organizational
agility and helps minimize operational
overhead
now let's quickly talk about designing
resilient services
2021 Dora research report indicates
organizations that use robust tools and
automation increase their agility and
reliability by significant factor there
are few key themes from architecture
framework specifically from the
operation accidents and reliability that
we expect you have or will incorporate
in your deployment
automate your deployments whether it's
managing code or deploying workloads
you should use various automation tools
like Ci CD infrastructure as a code
Etc to minimize operator error
such automation enables you to
systematically write more code that will
perform robust testing and validation
for you
launch gradually with the ability to
roll back any changes so you keep your
systems healthy and users happy
use Google Cloud managed services like
GK autofiler manage instance group load
balances Cloud SQL Etc that minimize
your operational overhead
designed highly available system
tracking slis and Define slos which
focus on keeping your users happy
architecture framework documentation
covers many other best practices and
design principle that will help you
optimize your deployments here is an
example of a sample architecture that
has incorporated various managed
services like Cloud armor Google Cloud
load balancer apigee managed instance
group GK autopilot and Etc
such architecture provides better
scalability and reduces burden on your
operations team
your architecture design will vary based
on your use case or business needs main
point here is to Showcase value of
managed services in operationalizing
your workloads let Google help you take
care of maintaining availability of
these Services while you focus on
improving your applications
remember
optimization is a continuous ongoing
exercise and a robust architecture is
foundational key to achieving
operational excellence
in next sections we will talk more about
highlighted Google manage operations
tool over to you Rakesh
thanks omkar as you embark on your
operational Journey you should develop a
good understanding of the complete
portfolio of capabilities that help you
get your job done
so that way you can plan your day-to-day
tasks better and leverage the most
relevant capabilities to derive the most
value for your task
let's get started and dive deeper in the
past the portfolio of day two activities
was very Broad
and often required a multitude of
activities delivered through a wide
variety of tools
however as Cloud platforms have evolved
day two activities especially what is
considered the operation space have
gotten clustered into two broad groups
first many take two activities that were
performed manually in the past have
become automated and become integrated
into the core Cloud platform itself
these are native data capabilities that
are available with the compute Network
and storage services
for example things like Auto scaling
Auto patching Auto healing backups
runtime security postures are now
natively integrated into the platform
services and are highly automated
the second group of day two operations
activities are related to aggregate
observability across the entire platform
including gcp services and applications
that users Deploy on top of these
Services these activities are performed
either at a fleet level service level or
at an application Level these
observability capabilities include
monitoring logging tracing and auditing
and they help customers with
understanding the health of their gcp
deployments and troubleshooting problems
now last but not least is the top layer
as you can see in this picture which
provides different surfaces through
which these capabilities can be accessed
this includes apis sdks the Google
console and automation using tools like
terraform now as you plan your day two
activities it is critical to understand
the breadth and depth of these
capabilities and come up with a strategy
on how the organization will leverage
these capabilities now in this section
I'm going to talk about some of the best
practices related to using these Ops
products that I just talked talked about
and touch on some of the newer
capabilities we have announced recently
that support these best practices
so as we all know that there are three
pillars to observability data namely
metrics logs and traces
in many instances customers deploy
different collectors or agents for
collecting these signals now that can be
challenging from a collector
Administration point of view as well as
from a resource management point of view
now our first best practice
recommendation is to deploy unified
collectors that can help collect metrics
logs and phrases now this is certainly
possible with the open Telemetry
collector as well as with the unified
Cloud Ops agent offered by Google Now
second when it comes to logging
traditionally logs have been
unstructured or semi-structured
increasingly logs have become more
structured now we recommend that users
adopt structured logging with
unstructured logs the primary mode of
exploration tends to be very search
oriented
you can enforce some structure at query
time but that becomes quite onerous on
the users however if you generate
structured logs to begin with then it
becomes easier to apply additional
techniques including machine learning
analytics AI correlation Etc to easily
find patterns and outliers
now this comes in very handy and complex
and highly distributed applications
and lastly as applications become more
complex it becomes increasingly
important to collect richer context from
your signals whether you collect that
through labels in metrics or through
fields in structured log events this
context helps you slice and dice the
data and correlate it amongst the
different signals now it is increasingly
critical to capture a unique identifier
like a trace ID that spans a user
request across all services and use that
context in making troubleshooting much
easier
now let me introduce a new capability
that helps you take advantage of
structured logs and all the rich context
that you can capture from these logs
until now when you store logs in Cloud
logging they were stored in a
proprietary store and had a query
language that enabled you to search
through these logs now with log
analytics we're integrating Cloud
logging with bigquery and making
bigquery the native store for logs today
we're announcing the public preview for
login lytics this change enables users
to now tackle a variety of new types of
use cases first you can store all your
log business data security data and
operational log data in one single
location and be able to scale that to
petabyte levels you do not need to copy
the data log log data from an
operational store to another location
when you want to integrate it with
business data for analysis
for analyzing the log data itself for
faster troubleshooting you can use the
power of SQL and bigquery analytical
functions
so in addition to searching through logs
you can do aggregations group buys joins
and other pivot operations on your log
data to address the unknown unknown
category of problems which are
increasingly common in distributed agile
environments third you can join the
operational log data with other business
data in a bigquery link or a warehouse
and come up with real-time business
insights and how they cross correlate
with the log data last but not least you
can Leverage The Power of bqml and
create machine learning based models for
correlation forecasting and anomaly
detection
the second group of best practices are
related to building your observability
footprint based on Open Standards now
over the past two decades one of the big
challenges for operators was to keep up
with the data collection problem for
metrics and logs there were many
proprietary Solutions and all of them
were siled and incomplete users spend
more time figuring out how to ingest
data rather than how to derive
actionable insights and get their jobs
done
adopting Open Standards like open
Telemetry can reduce the data collection
Pane and enable you to focus on using
analytics for your operational use cases
in addition to open apis and standards
there is a rich open source ecosystem
available that enables you to adopt and
deploy tools for a variety of different
observability use cases
this includes tools like Prometheus
elastic Jaeger Etc so we recommend that
users use tools and services that are
compatible with this open source
ecosystem these tools can be either do
it yourself implementation or offered as
compatible managed Services now lastly
we have often seen the tools offered in
these OSS ecosystems work well as
starter tools but as your business grows
and your services begin to grow some of
the OSS tools begin to have scaling
problems and customers also realize that
managing and operating these
observability services on your own
becomes a challenge in such cases you
can look for managed services that
support these open apis and open
interfaces but they're supported on the
back end by proprietary implementations
that address the scaling and
globalization challenges of the open
source implementations now I want us to
take a look at one set service that
Google offers that supports open
interfaces with a proprietary
implementation Google offers managed
service for Prometheus this is an
example of a managed service that is
compatible with open source interfaces
of Prometheus but is delivered not just
by running the OSS Prometheus but by
replacing the data store and the query
engine with a proprietary implementation
let us look at what that means we all
know that Prometheus is great and very
popular however we have seen that the
open source implementation has three
problems a it is hard to scale out as it
was primarily designed to scale up
B it is hard to make Global meaning if
you have multiple instances of
Prometheus it is hard to run Global
queries across these instances lastly
once you have multiple instances
developers start spending more and more
time managing Prometheus now Google
marriage Prometheus offers a managed
service that addresses these challenges
by supporting the apis for collecting
data and quoting data using prompt UL
but it stores and manages the data in
Google's proprietary time series
database called monitor Monarch is a
highly scalable monitoring service
now when users want to switch their own
instance to a managed service they
simply have to replace the OSS
Prometheus Upstream binary with the
Google offered Prometheus binary this
distribution scrapes the data exactly
like the OSS version but it writes the
data to the Google packet now once that
is done users can then run prom ql
compatible queries against Google's data
store and everything just continues to
work as it was working before
now this solution has a very low
friction for adoption and all your
existing dashboards and workflows just
continue to work
over to your own curve
thank you Rakesh let's look at some more
tools from operations portfolio that
Rakesh discussed
as your deployment grows so does the
networking complexity it's valuable to
understand how your network behaves
especially when things break and you're
looking to fix issues with complex
dependencies Network Intelligence Center
or automated analytics and observability
platform deepens its ability to
proactively monitor visualize and
troubleshoot Network Health your op
teams can now focus on a single place to
view Network deployments understand
traffic flows quickly identify issues
and focus on improving Network
performance
here are new features launching under
Network Intelligence Center
Network analyzer module which
automatically monitors environments for
network misconfiguration and potential
failures Network visibility for customer
has also been enhanced with both latency
metric for Google Cloud to internet
traffic in performance dashboard and new
top talkers view in network topology
so that you can quickly identify and
monitor largest contributors to egress
and optimize those deployment for
performance or cost
when it comes to apis apigee can help
you minimize many operational problems
and improve observability we understand
many customers now want to improve their
deployment resiliency by incorporating
API driven strategy
breaking your services into smaller
manageable apis lets you isolate
incidents and improve agility of your
devops team apigee API monitoring
provides real-time insights into API
performance that helps you ensure apis
are healthy and operational
apigee analytics allows you to view
long-term trends so you can optimize and
improve end user experience
anomaly detection are new feature
continually monitors API data and
performs statistical analysis to
distinguish true anomalies from random
fluctuations in the data that helps you
reduce mean time to detect API issues
additionally here is a quick highlight
on new apigee security features that
help you one quickly address
misconfigured apis by creating profiles
that are continuously monitored to
provide you recommendations and take
appropriate actions two detect malicious
Bots within your API traffic to protect
from abuse
hope you see the value of using managed
services that will supercharge your
applications
let's bring it all together
Rakesh mentioned that the portfolio of
tools that span across various domains
and we discussed few of them today
here are many other Google products and
with capabilities to help you improve
your operations in Google Cloud we
understand it can become an overhead in
itself to view various tools
individually and understand insights
Here Comes active assist a portfolio of
intelligent tools that helps you
optimize your Cloud operations
you can see here that activases runs
through nearly all gold cloud and
provides you Insight across various
product in one single place whether you
are interested in security cost
networking compute data or operations
we've got intelligence for you
we hope you got a sneak preview of
various Google Cloud tools to improve
your data operations
here is a link to architecture framework
where you can discover many more such
best practices you can also connect with
us via Google Cloud Community to engage
in EMA discussions share insights or
learn from the community
last but not the least we would also
like to thank many googlers who helped
bring this session together thank you so
much for listening to our session
[Music]